تاريخ بات رمادا نيران حولت العلم الى
ظلام
هويه فقدت في مسكنها مكتبات حرقت بعد ان
احتفظت بعشرات المخطوطات والكتب النادره
لعشرات الاعوام استقوت النار هنا على
جامعه المشرق الشهيره لدى ابنائها استقرت
في قلبها لساعات ليلا فلا بردا ولا سلامه
تغيرت ولم تعد حافظه للتاريخ كما عهدها
السودان
ست جامعات في الخرطوم التهمتها النيران
اغلبها يمثل رمزيه كبيره لاعوام طويله
لاكتنازها كتبا نادره بلغات عده تباها بها
اهلها
قبل الاستهداف بالحرق تحطيم وعمليات سرقه
ونهب للممتلكات الماديه لا المعنويه
لجامعه ام درمان وغيرها استهداف واضح
للصروح التعليميه في الايام القليله
الماضيه ما وصفه مثقفون بطعمه للذاكره
السودانيه غذاء السالم العربيه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات